it's win after win after win ready for
you you must be ecstatic also you cross
2700 for the first time in your career
how do you feel right now and which one
is more important being only half a
point behind the leader and getting
those victories or crossing 2700.
um yeah actually there's similarly
important I think around 2014 I decided
that okay maybe I'll never achieve my
full potential but I still had three
kind of long-term goals I wanted to
achieve in my career one was to meddle
at an Olympiad which back then seemed
like it would be very difficult even
though we had a strong team and very
good team chemistry our team was not one
of the very top teams obviously I was
fortunate to be on the 2016-2018 teams
which did metal when our teams were
super strong so that was accomplished
and the other two were to reach 2700 and
to win the US Championship so I'm very
happy I'm 2700 at least in library right
now but uh yeah seems like U.S
Championship is obviously these days is
the hardest one to uh to achieve
absolutely but you're definitely In
Contention to potentially reach your
final goal
what's going to come after that yeah you
win it what's going to come after that
oh yeah I've been thinking a little bit
like what do I really want to do I guess
I would like to get into some of these
like Elite events so obviously I need to
raise my rating up to probably at least
like 27 30 to have some chance to get
invited some of the very highest events
and I don't know it would just be nice
to play in some super tournaments I
haven't really had that opportunity I
think American cup I got to play with
some of the really top players and that
was great for me so I would like to do
that on a more regular basis well the
climb never stops so let's take a look
at today's game you guys started off
with uh the Berlin and actually Yasser
was telling us a story about his
roommate Alexander shabalov speaking
with elshon and telling him hey just go
play the Berlin make a draw
he was trying to make a Droid suit like
but you were still keeping the tension
in the position were you harboring hopes
of potentially winning this one I mean I
don't think he was trying to make a job
he want to make a drive probably like
Castle on move four play rookie why
didn't get a symmetrical position yes I
mean the line he played is a line with
Bishop takes C6 Knight bd2 is one of the
most critical lines I used to play this
basically every game with white against
the Berlin
um Sam Shanklin actually played it in
round one of this tournament against me
so no I thought there would just be a
game here but I didn't really like the
way I played it I mean when he started
to play A4 which was I didn't expect A4
at all
um yeah also here by the way after
Knight C5 Knight takes E5 I don't know
objectively but it looked quite
interesting F takes E5 Queen H5 king f8
queen takes E5 96 I thought long Castle
and I give Queen F6 Queen A5 he keeps
the Queens on and he'll try to play like
Rook F1 F4 and just push his pawns and
okay I suspected it wasn't bad
objectively but it still looked quite
difficult to play exactly yeah yeah yeah
your king is still unsafe uh definitely
an interesting option but he decided to
shy away from that
and uh yeah here this A4 and I spent a
really long time on Bishop A6
um yeah he wants to just play A5 but the
other thing is let's say if I castle at
any moment he's ready to play D4 and
then if I take take he has at least
Knight takes and queen C4 check
so it was possible that maybe I should
have castled early and just simplified
maybe this is still around equal but
yeah I played this move Bishop A6 and
it's kind of a weird move and I wasn't
really sure what's uh going on so the
point is
not just pressuring D3 but I'm also
covering C4 so now I'm prepared to
Castle in the future and then when he
plays D4 uh yeah Castle's short and when
he plays D4 and we do the same line I'll
cover C4 so yeah he played B4 which I
expected okay Rook d8 B5 I know maybe if
you go Castle the same thing after a B5
right B5 and then D4 yeah and it's even
better yeah so Rook d8 B5 Bishop B7
um Queen B3 to protect B5 and prepare A5
and here I play Queen F7 and here I
don't think G3 was the best I thought
he'd just play A5 I thought G3 was too
slow so he must have been uh worried
about Knight F4 which is probably what I
was going to play take take I thought a
b a b for K7 or B8 but I mean he can
never be worse and I wasn't sure if he's
actually just like clearly better if
it's around equal yeah he could play C4
let's say C4 rook d8 and Knight D5 96
and I didn't really see how he's
breaking through and I thought maybe
like very slowly I can unwind because
yeah I mean my Bishop is stuck but he
has no way to pressure it as far as I
saw so he can try to slowly maybe play
on the king side but I thought maybe I'm
holding this but this was what I was
most concerned about in G3 G3 allowed A5
after which I felt much better
absolutely and the engine was
recommending your position especially
once you've managed to play B5 yeah B5
was stabilized then
and yeah I think okay next very
interesting moment was after D4 Queen H5
D5 Knight F4 very uh unexpected
complications and here I think he just
blundered I was expecting okay the
engine shows GF but that looks worse for
white I was expecting uh maybe Knight
three to H4
yeah and here yeah I was considering
this line G5 Knight G2 and I have Knight
H3 but after King H1 Queen F3 I thought
if he just protects like Rooker D2 I can
open my Bishop at any moment with B4 but
I wasn't sure I mean it's a very very
weird position okay apparently I have
Bishop D3 threat which I didn't notice
but yeah very weird so after G5 Knight
G2 one yeah move 26. one option I was
thinking about was Queen E2
um and then if he takes I take with
check and take on C3 and support it with
B4
um and if he doesn't take then I at
least have Perpetual like Knight H3 King
and Shawn Knight F2 King G1 and H3 King
H1 and then I wasn't sure actually if I
should play for more yeah because he has
compensation I mean G5 is was quite
weakening so this still would have been
very unclear I think we both had low
time but I think Knight five H4 he
started kind of shaking yeah you started
kind of like shaking his head a little
bit Yeah and obviously G5 was logical
move and I I realized he just blundered
it I guess and after that you uh
converted swiftly Ray congratulations a
hatrick for you when's the last time you
scored a hat-trick
oh I'm I'm not sure I think in most wins
I had against strong opposition was in
one of the Fall Classics I think 2019
fall classic
um I believe I beat five 2600s in a row
so that was one of my best results yeah
that's impressive for sure guys
yeah well first of all you came in Ray
with a 28-31 performance rating today's
result will certainly add to that uh
what happened between the five draws
rest day and three wins because if we
can put it in a can
and market and sell it uh we've got a
million dollar idea though what happened
you're winning on through on the trot
I really don't think I'm playing like
much better or anything I think I'm
playing at a similar level as I have
been the whole tournament it's just in
the first four rounds I played you know
like Sam Shanklin and a bunch of like
2750s and I had three blacks and one
white
um and then I had white against Darius
in round five uh where I was pressing I
had very good chances to win that game
but I missed my chance and he defended
well so that was the first half and then
I think I just kept playing pretty well
in the second half and I think my
punches just have given me more chances
um it's as simple as that well
congratulations Ray and may all your
goals uh come true exactly yes great
goals great motivation well done well
done uh keep it up indeed and by the way
the results are coming